the Commonwealth is about to get a
little more interesting for Xbox one
owners the start of a beta test for
fallout 4 mods on Xbox one is drawing
ever closer and you should know now
whether or not you'll be a part of it
invites for the upcoming beta were sent
out this morning according to a tweet
from Bethesda registration for the beta
began earlier in May with those who were
accepted being notified by email today
that's right Xbox one owners can soon
get their hands on exploding chickens
immersive lawn flamingos and cuddles the
companion gorilla there's no indication
if another wave of invites will be sent
out so if you didn't get an email today
you may be stuck waiting until the
official launch of mods there's no date
on when that's set to happen though
Bethesda had previously said it expected
to launch mods on Xbox one in May and on
ps4 in June an update deployed last week
following the release of the for harbor
DLC prepared the xbox one version of the
game for the beta for even more on the
for Harbor expansion and all your
fallout 4 news stay tuned to gamespot
com